This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供依赖与心理健康课程。获取相关能力
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enriching to service of the community
对于陪伴和支持面临挑战的人们至关重要。建立一份造福社区的充实职业
francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French. It's possible with the CIT. Visit CollageLacacC.
全国各地的法语使用者。不要让法语质量打折扣。CIT可以做到。访问CollageLacacC。
D.C. D.M. An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health Supporting, supported by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes.
D.C. D.M. 一项由国家健康培训联盟支持，并由加拿大卫生部资助的倡议。那些眼睛里什么都没有。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty.
它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个目睹了Creveit和DePippo谋杀案的女人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。我说我没有罪。
I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats.
我会带着遗憾离开。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听Bone Valley频道中的Devil's Quarry。快乐至关重要，但也难以捉摸，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程，Joy 101。这是一个由我，Hoda Kotby主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的广播聊天。
Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast.
打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的Hoda Kotfi主持的Joy 101。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nandes, and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are?
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是Javier Chichariot-O-Nandes，在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在Drink Chams播客上，我们正在与文化界最热门的名字交谈，比如Sway Lee。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？
I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversation.
我很感激。我看到了，但我心想，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。比如Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在只发行了大约五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。是的，那是一个很好的态度。无论什么时代，Drink Chams都会为您带来最大的名字和最不加过滤的对话。
Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. for another episode. Today we are going to talk about anxiety, but not in the usual way that we normally talk about anxiety or not in the usual way that anxiety is spoken about. Generally, we are going to do instead a complete and in-depth look into the neuroscience behind why anxiety happens, why it lingers, why it continues to be this frustrating, sometimes like, uncontrollable part of life. I think knowing the intricacies behind anxiety and understanding the neuroscience behind
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的Drink Chams。大家好。我是Jemma Spike，欢迎回到《你20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来参加另一集。今天我们要谈论焦虑，但不是我们通常谈论焦虑的方式，也不是通常谈论焦虑的方式。相反，我们将对焦虑发生的原因、为何挥之不去、为何继续成为生活中这种令人沮丧、有时甚至是无法控制的一部分进行全面而深入的神经科学研究。我认为了解焦虑背后的复杂性并理解其背后的神经科学
the reactions that are going on in our brain is honestly sometimes the most important step in becoming less anxious because you start to like distance yourself from the feelings. You start to remove personal blame. You start to understand the systems better. And you are able to apply logic and this information to your feelings that I think counteracts the, I don't know, counteracts the illogical nature of anxiety. That's what's been really helpful for me. And I think just being able to explain what I'm feeling, how I'm feeling, why I'm feeling, whatever I am puts this distance between me and my anxiety. So that's what we're going to do today from talking about the function of different brain areas to neurotransmitters, cell networks,
大脑中正在发生的反应，老实说，有时是变得不那么焦虑的最重要一步，因为你开始与这些感觉保持距离。你开始消除个人指责。你开始更好地理解这些系统。并且你能够将逻辑和这些信息应用到你的感觉中，我认为这抵消了，我不知道，抵消了焦虑的不合逻辑的本质。这对我有很大帮助。而且我认为仅仅能够解释我的感受、我的感觉方式、我为什么会有这种感觉，无论是什么，都在我和我的焦虑之间建立了这种距离。所以这就是我们今天要做的，从谈论不同大脑区域的功能到神经递质、细胞网络，
the neuroscience of fear. There is a lot to cover. That is honestly, as a little bit of a psychology nerd, you guys know this, I find it's so fascinating, not typically spoken about. So without further ado,
恐惧的神经科学。有很多内容要涵盖。老实说，作为一个心理学书呆子，你们知道这一点，我发现这非常迷人，通常不会被谈论。所以事不宜迟，
let's get into the neuroscience behind your anxiety. Firstly, why does anxiety feel so serious? Even if we rationally know, even if we constantly know, even if we consciously know, like, the world isn't ending. Like, I'm going to be okay. This thing is actually not a threat. Why does our brain still take it to the extreme? Anxiety feels so serious because your brain is not built to be calm. It is not built to be fair. It's especially not
让我们进入你焦虑背后的神经科学。首先，为什么焦虑感觉如此严重？即使我们理性地知道，即使我们不断地知道，即使我们有意识地知道，世界并没有结束。就像，我会没事的。这件事实际上并不是威胁。为什么我们的大脑仍然将其推向极端？焦虑感觉如此严重，因为你的大脑不是为了冷静而构建的。它不是为了公平而构建的。它特别不
interested in your sense of fulfillment at all. It doesn't care if you're happy. First and foremost, it is built to protect you. It doesn't. not, it does not care if you feel fulfilled. It doesn't care if you feel okay. It cares that you're alive. The system, your brain system, the system behind your anxiety would rather overreact and protect you than underreact and have something terrible happen. One of the most useful ways neuroscientists now explain this is through prediction, a prediction model of anxiety. our brain predicts more than it reacts. So much of what your unconscious brain is doing throughout the day is essentially just like constantly, constantly making predictions about what is likely to happen next.
对你的成就感一点也不感兴趣。它不在乎你是否快乐。首先，它旨在保护你。它不，它不在乎你是否感到满足。它不在乎你是否感觉良好。它在乎的是你还活着。这个系统，你的大脑系统，你焦虑背后的系统，宁愿反应过度并保护你，也不愿反应不足而导致可怕的事情发生。神经科学家现在解释这一点最有效的方法之一是通过预测，一种焦虑的预测模型。我们的大脑预测多于反应。你的无意识大脑全天所做的大部分工作本质上只是像不断地、不断地对接下来可能发生的事情做出预测。
It consumes a large part of our unconscious mind. In anxiety or amongst people who have anxiety, those predictions become more tilted towards threat and uncertainty. Whereas with someone who doesn't have anxiety, those predictions are more realistic and they're easier to dismiss, which if you are somebody who is anxious probably feels literally impossible. I don't think I've ever been able to dismiss an anxious thought in my life without observing it, interrogating it, overthinking it. But this is what happens in the minds of people without anxiety. They don't have the same, what we call learnt uncertainty. This is something that a paper in 2022, I think was published, 2022 describes, where essentially, if you have anxiety, your brain has become primed to look for all
它消耗了我们无意识思维的很大一部分。在焦虑中，或者在患有焦虑症的人群中，这些预测变得更加倾向于威胁和不确定性。而对于没有焦虑的人来说，这些预测更现实，更容易被驳回，如果你是一个焦虑的人，这可能感觉简直是不可能的。我不认为我这辈子在不观察它、审问它、过度思考它的情况下能够驳回一个焦虑的想法。但这就是没有焦虑的人的思想中发生的事情。他们没有我们所说的习得性不确定性。这是2022年的一篇论文，我想是发表的，2022年描述的，本质上，如果你有焦虑，你的大脑已经被启动去寻找所有
the things in a situation that you don't understand, all the things that you aren't certain of, and fill in those gaps with whatever will be the worst case scenario so that you can prepare. This is why your anxiety can become so all-consuming, because it is focused on ambiguity. It is obsessed with uncertainty and the possibility of threat, and that possibility is always going to be there. It is a fact of life. That's part of being alive, but our brain can't help but fixate on it. This helps explain why your brain becomes like obsessed with certain thoughts, sensations, or themes, or what ifs. The very things that it cannot solve or cannot know for certain are the things that it becomes most obsessed with. It is not because those things are objectively the most important
情况中你不理解的事情，所有你不确定的事情，并用最坏的情况来填补这些空白，以便你可以准备。这就是为什么你的焦虑会变得如此消耗一切，因为它专注于模糊性。它痴迷于不确定性和威胁的可能性，而这种可能性将永远存在。这是生活的事实。这是活着的一部分，但我们的大脑忍不住要盯着它看。这有助于解释为什么你的大脑变得像痴迷于某些想法、感觉或主题，或假设。它无法解决或无法确定的事情正是它变得最痴迷的事情。这不是因为这些事情客观上是最重要的
part of reality. It's not that they're more likely to happen. It's not that they're more common. It is just this anxious fallacy that the more I worry, the more it must be true. The truth is it's just that your brain has assigned these hypotheticals as important to think about, more because they are scary, more because they are things that you can fixate on because there are so many possibilities, less because they are likely to happen. The other thing that this threat detection system is built to do is generalize based on past experiences. Being the machine that it is, your brain is a machine, once you may have experienced one dangerous or distressing situation, it becomes easier for your brain to then assume that every
现实的一部分。并不是它们更有可能发生。并不是它们更常见。这只是这种焦虑的谬论，即我越担心，它就越一定是真的。事实是，只是你的大脑将这些假设指定为需要考虑的重要事项，更多是因为它们很可怕，更多是因为它们是你可能固执己见的事情，因为有太多的可能性，而不是因为它们可能发生。这个威胁检测系统被构建来做的另一件事是基于过去的经验进行概括。作为它那样的机器，你的大脑是一台机器，一旦你可能经历过一次危险或痛苦的情况，你的大脑就更容易假设每一个
situation has the possibility of morphing into that worst case scenario. This is what is often referred to as fear generalization. And it is why anxiety tends to grow and expand over time. You know, you can have a panic attack in a supermarket once and then over time as your brain begins to expect this fear in more and more situations, now you start to dread going into any supermarket, going into anywhere that's public, going anywhere where there are like people around you. You know, one humiliating social moment can spread into anxiety around eye contact, public speaking, being perceived at all. One scary bodily sensation can change. generalize into the fear of exercise, fear around caffeine, heat, crowds, even excitement.
情况都有可能演变成那种最坏的情况。这就是通常所说的恐惧泛化。这就是为什么焦虑往往会随着时间的推移而增长和扩大。你知道，你可以在超市里恐慌发作一次，然后随着时间的推移，当你的大脑开始在越来越多的情况下期待这种恐惧时，现在你开始害怕进入任何超市，去任何公共场所，去任何周围有人的地方。你知道，一个羞辱性的社交时刻可以蔓延到对眼神交流、公开演讲、被感知到的焦虑。一个可怕的身体感觉可以改变。泛化为对运动的恐惧、对咖啡因、热量、人群甚至兴奋的恐惧。
These, like, it sounds irrational, right, that that fear could spread so rapidly, but it's, it may be irrational, it's not random. It's fear generalization. Now, this is where anxiety gets really irritating, because it's, because it starts to reach all these, like, broader aspects of life that shouldn't be scary. Like, why do I have this reaction, the same reaction to getting a cup of coffee as I would, being chased by a tiger. Well, you know, from the outside, yes, ordering a coffee is trivial, but from the inside, these small moments encompass multiple anxiety-inducing aspects and multiple moments of ambiguity. It might involve being watched, speaking whilst you're feeling shaky, making a mistake, feeling trapped in the queue, noticing your heart
这些，听起来不合理，对吧，这种恐惧会传播得如此迅速，但它，它可能是不合理的，它不是随机的。这是恐惧泛化。现在，这就是焦虑变得非常令人恼火的地方，因为它，因为它开始触及所有这些，像，生活中更广泛的方面，这些方面不应该是可怕的。比如，为什么我对喝一杯咖啡有这种反应，和我被老虎追赶时的反应一样。好吧，你知道，从外面看，是的，点咖啡是微不足道的，但从内部看，这些小瞬间包含了多个诱发焦虑的方面和多个模糊的时刻。它可能涉及被注视、在你感到颤抖时说话、犯错、感到被困在队列中、注意到你的心
rate, you know, worrying that you'll panic, that you'll blush, freeze, that people will judge you, to the conscious, rational part of you, it is just a quick interaction. You are just ordering a coffee. But really, the brain is not only, it's not just computing the objective event, it's computing the meaning behind the event and the meaning and the harm or the anxiety of past experiences, and it's sending in the whole army. It thinks that every situation could become the worst thing ever. When we feel this sense of anxiety, our bodies and minds react in a way that basically makes it as easy as possible to get away, to notice more, to be more alert, to stay on guard, to fight back.
率，你知道，担心你会恐慌，你会脸红、僵住，人们会评判你，对于你清醒、理性的部分来说，这只是一个快速的互动。你只是在点咖啡。但实际上，大脑不仅在计算客观事件，它还在计算事件背后的意义以及过去经验的意义和伤害或焦虑，并且它正在派遣整个军队。它认为每一种情况都可能成为有史以来最糟糕的事情。当我们感到这种焦虑感时，我们的身体和思想以一种基本上使逃跑、注意到更多、更加警觉、保持警惕、反击变得尽可能容易的方式做出反应。
From the bodies and the brain's point of view, this is useful. Putting us into this activated state is useful because if something dangerous does happen out of this hypothetical situation we've created, it's best to be prepared. But when there's a false alarm, and if you have anxiety, It's constant false alarms. This bodily reaction starts to feel disproportionate and starts to really dominate over all other feelings. This is where the distinction between immediate fear and sustained anxiety becomes really interesting. A 2020 or 2003, I think, actually 2003 review published in the European Journal of Pharmacology,
从身体和大脑的角度来看，这是有用的。让我们进入这种激活状态是有用的，因为如果这种我们创造的假设情况中确实发生了危险的事情，最好做好准备。但当出现误报时，如果你有焦虑，那就是不断的误报。这种身体反应开始感觉不成比例，并开始真正主导所有其他感觉。这就是即时恐惧和持续焦虑之间的区别变得非常有趣的地方。2020年或2003年，我想实际上是2003年发表在《欧洲药理学杂志》上的一篇评论，
looked at evidence from animal and human studies and basically was trying to figure out like, why is this overreaction happening? Essentially what they found was that in the brain of somebody without anxiety, the amygdala, the switch that turns off the amygdala and turns off the fear response is just as receptive as the same switch getting turned on. So basically, yes, their fear may spike in similar ways to us. Their anxiety may spike to similar things. But, it can be turned off just as quickly, meaning that sensations are allowed to kind of transpire, occur, and then we're able to move on. In the brains of people with anxiety, in the amygdala, amygdala's of people with anxiety, that switch, that same switch, can be turned on just as quickly,
查看了来自动物和人类研究的证据，基本上试图弄清楚，为什么会发生这种过度反应？本质上他们发现，在没有焦虑的人的大脑中，杏仁核，那个关闭杏仁核并关闭恐惧反应的开关，与打开恐惧反应的开关一样具有接受性。所以基本上，是的，他们的恐惧可能会以类似于我们的方式激增。他们的焦虑可能会因类似的事情而激增。但是，它可以同样快地被关闭，这意味着感觉被允许以某种方式发生、出现，然后我们能够继续前进。在患有焦虑症的人的大脑中，在患有焦虑症的人的杏仁核中，那个开关，同一个开关，可以同样快地被打开，
but it cannot be turned off. So a lot of people think that it's the on switch that's broken, right? The amygdala is more receptive, more reactive. That is definitely true in some situations, but really where anxiety comes from is not the immediate fear. It is the inability to downregulate that fear. It is the inability to turn off that fear. Another really important idea here is about interception. And this is basically the brain's ability to sense and interpret what is happening inside your body and react accordingly. The American neuroscientist, Arthur Craig, he talks about this in that same paper or one, I think,
但它无法被关闭。所以很多人认为开启开关坏了，对吧？杏仁核更具接受性，反应更强烈。这在某些情况下绝对是真的，但焦虑真正来自的不是即时恐惧。而是无法下调这种恐惧。是无法关闭这种恐惧。这里另一个非常重要的想法是关于内感受。这基本上是大脑感知和解释身体内部正在发生的事情并做出相应反应的能力。美国神经科学家Arthur Craig在同一篇论文中谈到了这一点，或者一篇，我想，
one published very soon after, and he argues that the brain is not just mapping what is happening outside the body, it's also mapping what's happening inside the body. So it's also thinking about heart rate, breathing, temperature, pain, muscle tension, nausea, and it's using that information to actually help construct our emotions about our external environment as well and how we should react. Essentially, it's a two-way street. Yes, our emotions control our bodily reactions, our bodily reactions control our emotions. The thing is, when we're anxious, our bodily reactions triggered by our anxiety, are really confusing because a lot is going on. Everything is like on full speed. And so our brain, getting locked into that two-way bidirectional relationship and
一篇发表在不久之后的论文，他认为大脑不仅在映射身体外部正在发生的事情，它还在映射身体内部正在发生的事情。所以它也在思考心率、呼吸、体温、疼痛、肌肉紧张、恶心，并且它正在利用这些信息来实际帮助构建我们关于外部环境的情绪以及我们应该如何反应。本质上，这是一条双向街道。是的，我们的情绪控制我们的身体反应，我们的身体反应控制我们的情绪。问题是，当我们焦虑时，由我们的焦虑触发的身体反应非常令人困惑，因为发生了很多事情。一切都像全速运转。所以我们的大脑，被锁定在那种双向关系和
stream of information, takes this as evidence that something must actually be going wrong. It takes that as evidence that our irrational emotions must be on to something. meaning that it continues to further stimulate us, continues to further activate the stress response. Essentially, what's happening is something freaks you out based on past experiences or based on an irrational fear. Your body is unable to turn off that sensation, that initial sensation of anxiety, that initial sensation of fear and being scared and tension, meaning that the body starts to take, your mind starts to take those bodily sensations as fact that something is actually going wrong.
信息流中，将其视为某事一定真的出了问题的证据。它将其视为我们的非理性情绪一定发现了什么的证据。这意味着它继续进一步刺激我们，继续进一步激活压力反应。本质上，正在发生的是某事基于过去的经验或基于非理性恐惧让你感到惊慌。你的身体无法关闭那种感觉，那种最初的焦虑感，那种最初的恐惧和害怕以及紧张的感觉，这意味着身体开始采取，你的思想开始将那些身体感觉视为某事确实出了问题的证据。
I'm hoping that you guys are kind of seeing this cycle here, right? Or just this like downward spiral where it becomes so difficult to interrupt these signals and say, actually no, everything is okay, we are fine because it just, the evidence that something is wrong is just as internal as it is external. or the evidence that things are okay is a lot weaker compared to this internal bodily signal that everything is actually on fire. Talking more about the neuroscience of this, that same researcher, Dr. Craig, expanded on this idea in a 2009 review published in like a neuro, I can't remember the name, but a neuroscience journal,
我希望你们能看到这个循环，对吧？或者只是这种像螺旋式下降，中断这些信号并说，实际上不，一切都很好，我们很好，变得如此困难，因为证据表明某事出了问题，就像内部一样，就像外部一样。或者证据表明事情很好，与这个内部身体信号相比要弱得多，即一切实际上都在着火。更多地谈论这个的神经科学，同一位研究人员，Craig博士，在2009年发表在像神经，我不记得名字了，但一个神经科学期刊上的一篇评论中扩展了这个想法，
and he focused on another part of the brain called the anterior insular. that as a brain region he argued is especially important for turning raw bodily signals into conscious subjective feelings. His claim is that people with anxiety may have a dysfunction in this region, meaning that like we were talking about with that mind-body connection, anxious feelings are more physically persuasive because we find it harder, that the insular finds it harder to argue or disentangle ourselves from what it sees as physical proof. Basically, it becomes harder in the brain of somebody with anxiety to shut down our own brain's interpretation of our own physical reactions as being evidence that something is truly wrong.
他专注于大脑的另一个部分，称为前脑岛。他认为这是一个大脑区域，对于将原始身体信号转化为有意识的主观感觉特别重要。他的主张是，患有焦虑症的人可能在这个区域有功能障碍，这意味着就像我们谈论的那种身心联系一样，焦虑的感觉在身体上更具说服力，因为我们发现它更难，脑岛发现更难争论或将我们自己与它视为物理证据的东西解开。基本上，在患有焦虑症的人的大脑中，关闭我们自己大脑对我们自己身体反应的解释作为某事确实出了问题的证据变得更加困难。
What I'm really trying to get out here is it's not you. It is all these systems. It is all this neurological stuff going on that means that we cannot separate a thought from a feeling. We cannot separate as well our emotional experience from our anxiety and from what's going on in our bodies. A 2004 study carried out by researchers from the University College, London, looked into this a little bit closer. They kind of wanted to figure out whether this was really the crux of why people are anxious or why some people have debilitating anxiety and some people don't. The researchers put 17 participants into an fMRI scanner and they asked,
我真正想在这里表达的是，这不是你。是所有这些系统。是所有这些正在发生的神经学东西，意味着我们不能将思想与感觉分开。我们也不能将我们的情感体验与我们的焦虑以及我们身体中正在发生的事情分开。2004年伦敦大学学院的研究人员进行的一项研究更仔细地研究了这一点。他们想弄清楚这是否真的是人们焦虑或为什么有些人有衰弱性焦虑而有些人没有的核心。研究人员将17名参与者放入fMRI扫描仪中，他们要求，
them to do a heartbeat detection task. Essentially, they said, we're not going to take your pulse in the usual external way. What do you think your heart rate is per minute? Essentially, how good are you at counting your own heart rate and figuring out your own pulse? Most interestingly, people who got a more accurate number who were like, yep, I think my heart rate is around 72 beats per minute, 49 beats per minute. It didn't matter if it was high or low, they were more accurate in their assessment reported stronger negative emotional experiences. What this paper essentially suggests is that your brain monitors your body closely to determine how scared it should be. So if your brain is highly tuned to internal changes, small shifts in
他们做一个心跳检测任务。本质上，他们说，我们不会以通常的外部方式测量你的脉搏。你认为你每分钟的心率是多少？本质上，你计算自己心率并找出自己脉搏的能力有多好？最有趣的是，得到更准确数字的人，他们说，是的，我认为我的心率大约是每分钟72次，每分钟49次。无论它是高还是低并不重要，他们在评估中更准确，报告了更强烈的负面情绪体验。这篇论文本质上建议，你的大脑密切监测你的身体以确定它应该有多害怕。所以如果你的大脑高度调谐到内部变化，微小的变化
heart rate, small shifts in breathing, tension in any way, that becomes more psychologically meaningful to it. In an anxious state, that means that the body constantly feels like there is, and the brain constantly feels like there is ample evidence internally that something is going wrong. Again, this is all because your mind would rather interrupt your peace 10 times unnecessarily than miss one thing that might have hurt you. That is why anxiety often feels bigger than the situation itself. And all of these neurological processes, all of these anatomical areas are all trying to keep that process going so that you survive. Going even deeper into the neuroscience behind your anxiety, we also obviously at some point
心率、呼吸的微小变化、任何方式的紧张，这对它来说在心理上变得更有意义。在焦虑状态下，这意味着身体不断感觉好像有，大脑不断感觉好像有充足的内部证据表明某事出了问题。同样，这一切都是因为你的思想宁愿不必要地打断你的平静10次，也不愿错过一件可能伤害你的事情。这就是为什么焦虑通常感觉比情况本身更大。所有这些神经过程，所有这些解剖区域都在试图保持这个过程，以便你生存。更深入地了解你焦虑背后的神经科学，我们显然在某个时候
need to talk about the role of certain neurotransmitters, specifically two neurotransmitters, gabber and glutamate. If you've been listening to this podcast for a while, you would have heard me talk about these so much, the two Gs, these two chemical messengers basically control. alongside a bunch of other things, but they are a big part of how reactive or regulated your brain is. In very simple terms, glutamate is what helps neurons fire and communicate. It gets them all excited. It stimulates them.
需要谈论某些神经递质的作用，特别是两种神经递质，GABA和谷氨酸。如果你听这个播客有一段时间了，你会听到我谈论这些很多，两个G，这两个化学信使基本上控制。除了其他一堆事情之外，但它们是你大脑反应性或调节程度的重要组成部分。用非常简单的术语来说，谷氨酸是帮助神经元放电和交流的东西。它让它们都兴奋起来。它刺激它们。
Gabba is the main inhibitory neurotransmitter, meaning it helps to quiet or dampen neural activity. It just, it calms everybody down. I always think about them as like good cop and bad cop in a way like glutamate or like this. I think about them as like glutamate is the fun, exciting aunt who like gives the kids all the sugar, riles them up with games, with candy, is like getting them all excited. And then Gabba is like the responsible parent who then has to like get everybody ready for bedtime and do like the grown up job. Research on anxiety disorders has argued that it's not simply that we have more glutamate, more of that excitatory neurotransmitter in our system, it's that we may also have less
GABA是主要的抑制性神经递质，这意味着它有助于安静或抑制神经活动。它只是，它让每个人都冷静下来。我总是把它们想成某种好警察和坏警察，比如谷氨酸或像这样。我把它们想成谷氨酸是那个有趣的、令人兴奋的阿姨，她给孩子们所有的糖，用游戏、糖果激怒他们，让他们都兴奋起来。然后GABA是那个负责任的父母，然后不得不让每个人为睡觉做好准备，做像成年人的工作。关于焦虑症的研究认为，不仅仅是我们系统中有更多的谷氨酸，更多的兴奋性神经递质，而是我们可能也有更少的
GABA, or we may be less receptive to GABA, or have an imbalance in both, which is why drugs that boost GABA signaling in the way that GABA can be received, like benzodiazepines, reduce acute anxiety, because the theory goes, they're balancing out the neurochemical reactions. This is another thing your anxiety may come down to. Of course, all these things are kind of happening at the same time. So it's not like these are different explanations. They're all combined. But sometimes what it does come down to on top of these other elements is just differences
GABA，或者我们可能对GABA的接受性较低，或者两者都有失衡，这就是为什么像苯二氮卓类药物那样增强GABA信号传导的方式，减少急性焦虑，因为理论认为，它们正在平衡神经化学反应。这是你的焦虑可能归结为的另一件事。当然，所有这些事情都是同时发生的。所以这不像这些是不同的解释。它们都结合在一起。但有时除了这些其他元素之外，它确实归结为只是差异
in your brain chemistry that increase or decrease your sensitivity to certain neurotransmitters that go on to shape how you feel in response to the world. I just think it's so fascinating that we have this intense emotional experience, that being our anxiety. and then when you start to understand it through a neuroscientific lens, it all makes sense. It all makes sense why it all feels so uncontrollable, because there are things operating behind the scenes that can't be brought into your control, that you do not have conscious say over that just leave you responding to the consequences or outcomes of the imbalance or of the lack or excess of activity. you'll probably know the frustration.
在大脑化学中，这会增加或减少你对某些神经递质的敏感性，这些神经递质会塑造你对世界的反应。我只是觉得非常迷人，我们有这种强烈的感官体验，即我们的焦虑。然后当你开始通过神经科学的视角理解它时，这一切都说得通。这一切都说得通为什么它感觉如此不可控，因为幕后有东西在运作，无法被带入你的控制，你没有意识上的发言权，只是让你对失衡或缺乏或过量活动的后果或结果做出反应。你可能知道这种挫败感。
If you have anxiety and you're listening to this episode, you have definitely had somebody tell you just to stop worrying about it or to simply stop thinking about it. What people without anxiety don't realize is that that would mean going against like everything that your brain in particular is programmed to do. Like you do not have the same efficient, top down, attentional control that the average person without anxiety has. Instead, you have a different attentional system, one that is stimulus driven, threat driven. Basically, for you, it is a lot
如果你有焦虑并且正在听这一集，你肯定有人告诉过你只要停止担心它或简单地停止思考它。没有焦虑的人没有意识到，这意味着违背你大脑特别编程要做的每一件事。就像你没有普通没有焦虑的人所拥有的那种高效的、自上而下的、注意力控制。相反，你有一个不同的注意力系统，一个是刺激驱动的，威胁驱动的。基本上，对你来说，这要多得多
harder to ignore the scary thoughts, to ignore the scary situations because anxiety is not only making the threat seem bigger. It's reducing your capacity for calm. It's reducing your capacity for goal-directed focus and rationalization. And it's also this weird conundrum whereby, in order to address our anxiety, like, we have, you know, trying to avoid it doesn't work. Like, when people say, worry about it less, think about it less, well, that actually can at times enlarge our fear and make us think about it more. I feel like by now, I feel like we all know about this very famous experiment, like the white bear experiment. You might also know it as the white elephant experiment to give a refresh. This was an experiment very famous in the 80s, where a researcher
难以忽视可怕的想法，忽视可怕的情况，因为焦虑不仅使威胁看起来更大。它正在降低你的冷静能力。它正在降低你的目标导向专注和合理化的能力。而且这也是一个奇怪的难题，即为了解决我们的焦虑，就像，我们有，你知道，试图避免它是不起作用的。就像，当人们说，少担心它，少想它，好吧，这实际上有时会扩大我们的恐惧并让我们更多地想它。我觉得到现在，我觉得我们都知道这个非常著名的实验，比如白熊实验。你可能也知道它是白象实验来刷新一下。这是一个在80年代非常著名的实验，其中一位研究人员
told a bunch of participants, whatever you do, don't think about a white elephant or don't think about a white bear. Every time you think about it, ring the bell. Ring the bell as soon as this thought hasn't intruded. He also told a bunch of participants, like, here is a list of things you can think about. You can think about the white bear. You can also think about this and this and this. Whatever you want to think about, you have complete permission to do it. When people were told to think about the bear less, when people were told not to think about it, it became a fixation point, right? It became this obsessional thing because why are we not allowed to think about it? What's wrong with this thing? What's bad about thinking about it that means that we can't do that? And your brain begins
告诉一群参与者，无论你做什么，都不要想白象或不要想白熊。每次你想到它，就按铃。一旦这个想法闯入，就按铃。他还告诉一群参与者，就像，这里有一份你可以想的事情的清单。你可以想白熊。你也可以想这个和这个和这个。无论你想想什么，你都有完全的许可去做。当人们被告知少想熊时，当人们被告知不要想它时，它就成了一个固着点，对吧？它成了这种强迫性的东西，因为为什么我们不允许想它？这个东西有什么问题？想它有什么坏处意味着我们不能那样做？而你的大脑开始
to run away with it. It's the same with your anxiety. Study after study shows when we are given instructions to suppress a thought, to ignore a stimulus, to ignore a thought, our level of fear towards that thought increases, firstly, but also we just think about it in excess of if we'd just been allowed to think about it casually all along. And because of this, anxiety becomes a self-perpetuating cycle that's really difficult to break, making our initial fears worse and worse and worse. So I feel like I've given you a lot of information. This is the neuroscientific side of this so far. Just to give you a little mini summary.
随之而去。你的焦虑也是如此。一项又一项的研究表明，当我们被指示抑制一个想法，忽视一个刺激，忽视一个想法时，我们对那个想法的恐惧程度首先会增加，但我们也只是想它，超过了如果我们一直被允许随意想它。正因为如此，焦虑成了一个自我延续的循环，真的很难打破，使我们最初的恐惧越来越严重。所以我感觉我已经给了你很多信息。这是到目前为止这方面的神经科学。只是给你一个小小的总结。
Your brain is built to protect you, not to fulfill you. All it cares about is your survival. There are certain areas in the brain that are in control of your survival and of detecting things that may threaten your survival. In people with anxiety, these areas aren't always operating properly and that creates a longer ongoing sense of fear towards ambiguous situations. There is also the combined changes in neurotransmitter levels that kind of explains this a little bit and also this inability to downregulate your fear or to rationally interoper interrupt your fear and say, hey, this actually isn't that important. This actually isn't going to
你的大脑旨在保护你，而不是满足你。它关心的只是你的生存。大脑中有某些区域控制你的生存并检测可能威胁你生存的事情。在患有焦虑症的人中，这些区域并不总是正常运作，这会产生对模糊情况的更长期的持续恐惧感。还有神经递质水平的综合变化，这在某种程度上解释了这一点，还有这种无法下调你的恐惧或理性地中断你的恐惧并说，嘿，这实际上并不那么重要。这实际上不会
happen. And to believe that. And so all of this shrinks our lives significantly to say the least. I want to break down how we can take those neuroscientific principles, though, and apply them in the opposite direction, knowing what we know about the neuroscience behind anxiety. How can we kind of take that knowledge, flip it on its head, and better for our anxious feelings. Happy Pride Months, Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. IHeart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival and we won't stop.
发生。并相信这一点。所以所有这些都极大地缩小了我们的生活，至少可以这么说。我想分解我们如何能够利用这些神经科学原则，尽管如此，并朝着相反的方向应用它们，了解我们所知道的关于焦虑背后的神经科学。我们如何能够以某种方式利用这些知识，将其颠倒过来，并更好地应对我们的焦虑感。快乐骄傲月，多伦多。骄傲是你创造自己空间、庆祝你存在的机会。IHeart Radio很自豪能成为多伦多骄傲节的官方赞助商，我们不会停止。
Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada, your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that, they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. I heart radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever.
庆祝骄傲。调大爱，收听IHeart Pride Canada，你的24-7广播流，这是你多伦多骄傲庆祝活动所需的唯一播放列表。骄傲太棒了，因为它给了很多人这种他们以前从未有过的可见性。我们有很多值得庆祝的多伦多。快乐骄傲。I heart radio。在那一刻，感觉它好像永远在持续。
I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career?
我不认为我会活下来。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案？是的，先生。恐惧说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？
Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. evil wake up i'm the woman saw the murder take place by crevette and de pippo anthony de pippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum i said i'm not guilty i'll take it to the grief listen to the devil's quarry on the iheart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts and to hear the devil's quarry ad free
是的，先生。强奸一个孩子的谋杀案。就像它能得到的一样糟糕。我想是的。邪恶醒醒我是那个目睹了Crevette和DePippo谋杀案的女人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。我说我没有罪。我会带着遗憾离开。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》，并收听《魔鬼的采石场》无广告版
with exclusive content subscribe to lava for good plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
带有独家内容，在Apple Podcasts上订阅Lava for Good Plus。嘿，我是Hoda Kotby，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。在一起，我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员Olivia Munn分享她如何克服激烈的健康挑战时。我经历了乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多了解产后抑郁症的人。
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. And there's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito and Andandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions.
我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。而且有很多令人兴奋的事情，因为他们的新星是Javier T. Torito和Andandez。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。而且我仍然有很多问题。
Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or bars? From everyday and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary.
我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常和平凡到深刻和非凡。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm here to connect.
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的和真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，脆弱性显露出来。阴谋论被摆上桌面，目标和教训被分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等我，我在这里连接。
We are here to connect. The Chicharito. And Javier and Chicharito-R-Nandes, and together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. Listen to learning to be human on IHard radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith.
我们在这里连接。Chicharito。和Javier和Chicharito-R-Nandes，与IHA Radio一起，我们将使平凡变得非凡。保持亲密。在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的粗俗描述，这些故事羞辱和指责，并将无家可归者描绘成一个整体。
We The Un House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host. And for years, I've created a space where the unhouse and their advocates can tell, their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed Unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Woody Enhous is a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill which are a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge
《We The Un House》是正在改变这一点的播客。我是Theo Henderson，创作者和主持人。多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者可以讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQTIA+社区，以及制定影响无家可归者生存法律的决策者。《Woody Enhous》是一个两次获得Webby和Signal奖的节目，地平线上有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周请收听我对Jill博士的采访，她是一位街头医生转型的网红，她与无家可归者社区的工作产生了巨大的
impact online and in her community listen to weevian housed on the iHeart radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast essentially what i'm saying is that as much as our brain is pushing us to have a certain reaction to fear and to ambiguity there is a way that we can rewire our brains away from anxious thoughts, knowing what we now know about the underlying neuroscience. We basically have to teach our brain new connections, new connections between ambiguous situations and the expected fear. And we do that by creating new associations between the things that we fear and what we think or what we know the outcome will be. Basically, rather than trying to completely erase all of our exposure to a trigger, rather than trying to avoid something that scares us at all costs,
在线和在她的社区中的影响，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Weevian Housed》。本质上，我所说的是，尽管我们的大脑在推动我们对恐惧和模糊性做出某种反应，但有一种方法可以让我们的大脑远离焦虑的想法，了解我们现在所知道的关于潜在神经科学的知识。我们基本上必须教我们的大脑新的连接，模糊情况与预期恐惧之间的新连接。我们通过在我们恐惧的事物与我们认为或我们知道结果会是什么之间建立新的关联来做到这一点。基本上，与其试图完全抹去我们对触发因素的所有接触，与其试图不惜一切代价避免让我们害怕的事情，
all we need to do is show our brain that a different outcome is possible. Remember, your brain is just a machine that learns through repeated patterns, repeated exposure, through repetition. The more that you associate this thing that you fear with something that is positive, the more that it learns to expect that in the future and it changes the X to Y prediction model that it's operating on. We need to have experiences. If you're going to use neuroscience to battle against your anxiety, you need to be focused on having experiences that contradict your anxious predictions, basically meaning you have to go further into the belly of your anxiety.
我们所要做的就是向我们的大脑展示不同的结果是可能的。记住，你的大脑只是一台通过重复模式、重复接触、通过重复学习的机器。你将你恐惧的这件事与积极的事情联系得越多，它就越学会期待未来，并改变它正在运行的X到Y预测模型。我们需要有经验。如果你要利用神经科学来对抗你的焦虑，你需要专注于拥有与你的焦虑预测相矛盾的经验，基本上意味着你必须更深入地进入你焦虑的腹部。
In psychology, we call this exposure therapy, I'm sure you've heard it. Essentially, what it's saying is if we assume every, for example, social interaction will always be on bearable. The most powerful way we can rewire that situation is by going into those feared situations and proving to ourselves that that catastrophic outcome is not going to happen or will not happen as often as we expect it to. Basically saying, your brain, my brain, you brain, you are lying to me. These predictions are false. We're basically trying to set up our anxiety in like a sting operation to prove that it's a liar by going into the room, going into the space, getting on the plane, standing up in front of the people,
在心理学中，我们称之为暴露疗法，我相信你一定听说过。从本质上讲，它的意思是，如果我们假设每一次社交互动都将是无法忍受的，那么我们能用来重塑这种局面的最有力的方法，就是进入那些令我们恐惧的情境，并向自己证明那种灾难性的结果并不会发生，或者不会像我们预期的那样频繁发生。简单来说就是，你的大脑、我的大脑、大家的大脑，都在对我撒谎。这些预测是错误的。我们基本上是在试图给焦虑设下一个“钓鱼执法”的陷阱，通过走进那个房间、那个空间、登上飞机、站在人群面前，来证明它是个骗子。
and undoing that prediction that everything is going to go terribly and providing proof that it's not. You know, if you fear speaking up in front of others because you think that everybody's going to judge you, everybody's going to notice how anxious you are, everybody is going to reject you, a way to kind of set up that prediction and to prove that it's false is to go into those situations more and more and more to prove that like that doesn't happen every time that actually that
并推翻那种“一切都会变得糟糕”的预测，提供证据证明事实并非如此。你知道，如果你害怕在别人面前发言，因为你认为每个人都会评判你，每个人都会注意到你有多焦虑，每个人都会拒绝你，那么一种设定预测并证明其错误的方法，就是不断地、反复地进入这些情境，去证明那种情况并不会每次都发生，实际上它
rarely happens the prediction model is false the new learning isn't necessarily this is always going to be fine or i'm always going to feel confident or there is nothing to fear the new learning is simply that, like, I can be in that fearful situation. A, it's probably not as likely as I thought, but B, I will survive regardless. There is also evidence that how you engage with the fear matters as well, not just the outcome. And that brings me to, like, our practical tips for dealing with an anxious mind. And the number one thing you can do other than exposure is to simply verbalize what you are feeling rather than keeping it stuck inside of your mind to fester. In 2015, they did this randomized control trial with people who were afraid of public speaking. And these people were
很少发生。预测模型是错误的，新的认知不一定是“一切都会好起来”或“我总是会感到自信”或“没什么好怕的”，新的认知仅仅是：我可以身处那种令我恐惧的情境中。A，它可能不像我想象的那么糟糕，但B，无论如何我都能挺过去。还有证据表明，你如何应对恐惧也很重要，而不仅仅是结果。这让我想到了我们应对焦虑心态的实用技巧。除了暴露疗法之外，你能做的第一件事就是简单地把你感受到的东西表达出来，而不是让它困在脑海里发酵。2015年，他们对一群害怕公开演讲的人进行了一项随机对照试验。这些人被
assigned to basically get up in front of a room and talk. And they were either asked to label their anxiety or to ignore it, meaning they were asked to either explicitly put their feelings and their fears about what was going to happen into words, or they were just going to have to do exposure and get up in front of people and see what happened. What they found was that people who were able to say, this is an anxious feeling, I'm scared here, my physical symptoms of anxiety, are really derived from this fear
分配到房间前面进行演讲。他们要么被要求标记自己的焦虑，要么被要求忽略它，这意味着他们要么被要求明确地用语言表达出他们的感受和对即将发生之事的恐惧，要么他们只是进行暴露练习，站在人群面前看看会发生什么。他们发现，那些能够说出“这是一种焦虑的感觉，我在这里感到害怕，我身体上的焦虑症状确实源于这种恐惧”的人，
and not from the fact that this situation is actually harmful. They did better almost every single time. Essentially, they were able to rewire their fear, not necessarily by suppressing their anxious thoughts, but actually by bringing the anxious thought more into their focus, being able to approach it and also see that it was a liar, see that it wasn't true, and see that it was something that operated beyond what they consciously and deliberately wanted to do. So that's one of the best things you can do if you're feeling anxious is just literally say, I am anxious. I know it goes against so much of how we think we're meant to process our emotions, which is to avoid them and to not acknowledge them. This is saying do the opposite.
而不是源于这种情况本身是有害的。他们几乎每次都表现得更好。从本质上讲，他们能够重塑恐惧，不一定是通过压抑焦虑的想法，而是通过将焦虑的想法更多地置于关注之下，能够接近它，并看到它是一个骗子，看到它不是真的，看到它是在我们有意识和刻意想要做的事情之外运作的。所以，如果你感到焦虑，你能做的最好的事情之一就是直白地说出来：“我很焦虑。”我知道这违背了我们认为自己应该处理情绪的许多方式，即回避它们、不承认它们。这其实是在说：反其道而行之。
This is saying go in deeper. Tip number two relies on a similar cognitive distancing technique. And it essentially says what I'm essentially going to tell you to do is to learn how to relate to your thoughts as mental events beyond you rather than facts that are coming from within you. In a really interesting series of studies from 2014, researchers found that using your name or a non-first-person pronoun or somebody else's name, during an anxious moment was an incredible form of emotional regulation. Basically, the first level of cognitive distancing from your anxiety would be saying,
这是在说：深入挖掘。第二个技巧依赖于类似的认知距离技术。它本质上是说，我将要告诉你要做的是，学会如何将你的想法视为你之外的心理事件，而不是来自你内心的事实。在2014年一系列非常有趣的研究中，研究人员发现，在焦虑时刻使用你的名字、非第一人称代词或别人的名字，是一种极好的情绪调节方式。基本上，与焦虑保持认知距离的第一层级是说：
I'm having an anxious thought. The second level, the level that they found was saying, Gemma is experiencing an anxious thought, or saying, giving your anxiety a completely different name. Basically, labeling the part of you that felt anxious as something that was operating outside of you. So, Kevin is making me feel anxious. Kevin's having a really bad day today. Brian is really trying to get me stirred up.
“我正在产生一个焦虑的想法。”第二层级，也就是他们发现的那个层级，是说“杰玛正在经历一个焦虑的想法”，或者给你的焦虑起一个完全不同的名字。基本上，将你感到焦虑的那部分标记为在你之外运作的东西。所以，“凯文让我感到焦虑。凯文今天过得很糟糕。布莱恩真的在试图激怒我。”
Noticing your anxious thoughts, not as just coming from you, but from something beyond you that you don't necessarily want or you don't have to necessarily associate with. So like when you feel fear, being like, instead of thinking, oh, my God, I feel, I feel fear, this is coming from me, this is intuition, being like, oh, that's Miranda again. That's Miranda being such like an asshole. Miranda's just like really getting on my nerves at the moment.
注意到你的焦虑想法，不是仅仅来自你，而是来自你之外的某个东西，你不一定想要它，也不必一定要与它产生关联。所以，当你感到恐惧时，不要想“天哪，我感到恐惧，这是来自我内心的，这是直觉”，而是想“哦，又是米兰达。米兰达真是个混蛋。米兰达现在真的让我很心烦。”
It stops you, the reason this works is because it stops you from completely embodying the thought as your own and puts the blame. or assigns the blame to an outside source. Why this works is because it stops, well, it doesn't completely stop, but it interrupts that body-mind connection that says, if fear and anxiety is coming from me internally, it must mean that it's saying something important. It must mean that it's given me some kind of signal, cue, hint about the state of the world around me. it must mean that I should be scared because, of course, we trust ourselves and we trust our own feelings the most and above all others. Obviously, if you're anxious or if you are somebody with
它之所以有效，是因为它阻止了你完全将这种想法视为你自己的，并将责任归咎于外部来源。它之所以有效，是因为它阻止了——好吧，它并没有完全阻止，但它中断了那种“如果恐惧和焦虑来自我的内心，那一定意味着它在传达什么重要的信息”的身心连接。它一定意味着它给了我某种关于周围世界状态的信号、线索或暗示。它一定意味着我应该感到害怕，因为当然，我们最信任自己，最信任自己的感受，胜过一切。显然，如果你感到焦虑，或者如果你是一个有
anxiety, we know from this research and from the neuroscience we've already spoken about that that connection and your ability to interpret those physical sensations is providing false evidence for things that aren't actually occurring or that aren't actually as dangerous as you think they are. So assigning the anxious thought, assigning the corresponding bodily sensations to an outside force, to a Kevin or a Brian or Miranda, this anxious little character that occasionally comes and visits you and makes you feel terrible, interrupts that, to your brain, logical assumption that to feel anxiety must mean that something is wrong because it is coming from you and who could you trust more than yourself?
焦虑症的人，我们从这项研究和我们已经讨论过的神经科学中知道，那种连接以及你解读这些身体感觉的能力，正在为那些实际上并未发生，或者实际上并不像你想象的那么危险的事情提供虚假的证据。所以，将焦虑的想法、相应的身体感觉分配给一种外部力量，分配给一个凯文、布莱恩或米兰达——这个偶尔来拜访你并让你感觉糟糕的焦虑小角色——会中断那种对你的大脑来说合乎逻辑的假设，即感到焦虑一定意味着出了什么问题，因为它来自你，而除了你自己，你还能信任谁呢？
This is kind of similar to my third tip, which is to bring in humor. Cal, you know, labeling your anxiety as Brian or Kevin or Miranda makes it kind of funny compared to like the intensity of the feeling. The opposite of anxiety is not peace, it is laughter. I don't know who said that, but they were a very, very wise individual. When our anxiety is bad, everything feels really serious because we know our mind is taking this as a life or death situation. That makes it difficult to laugh. So it makes it difficult to make it feel less serious than it is. But adding back in the ridiculousness of the situation
这和我的第三个技巧有点类似，那就是引入幽默。卡尔，你知道，把你的焦虑标记为布莱恩、凯文或米兰达，比起那种强烈的感受，会让它变得有点滑稽。焦虑的对立面不是平静，而是笑声。我不知道是谁说的，但他是一个非常、非常睿智的人。当我们的焦虑严重时，一切都感觉非常严肃，因为我们知道我们的大脑将其视为生死攸关的情况。这使得笑变得困难。所以这使得很难让它感觉不那么严肃。但重新加入这种情况的荒谬感，
snaps you out of the anxiety cycle much quicker than a lot of other techniques. And honestly, like anxiety is literally hilarious at times. Like it is hilarious how ridiculous and dramatic it is. the fact that it truly believes every single bad thing that could happen in the world could and will and is currently happening to you. The fact that it genuinely wants you to believe that is really funny. It's like a child. Our anxiety is like a little petulant child. And there's increasing evidence that laughing at the absurdity of our anxiety firstly helps by taking that nervous energy and turning those bubbles of fear into like feelings of excitement. It secondly helps because of that psychological distancing. But when speaking about neuroscience, the third way
能比许多其他技巧更快地让你从焦虑循环中跳出来。老实说，焦虑有时真的很滑稽。它有多荒谬和戏剧化，这真的很搞笑。它真的相信世界上可能发生的每一件坏事都可能、将会并且目前正在发生在你身上。它真心想让你相信这一点，这真的很滑稽。它就像一个孩子。我们的焦虑就像一个任性的小孩。越来越多的证据表明，嘲笑我们焦虑的荒谬性，首先通过将那种紧张的能量转化为兴奋感来提供帮助。其次，它因为那种心理距离而有所帮助。但在谈论神经科学时，第三种
that laughter helps is that it actually activates the parasympathetic nervous system. Like I said, the opposite of anxiety is not peace. It is laughter. Because when we laugh, it stimulates, laughter literally stimulates the vagus nerve. This is the primary component of our parasympathetic nervous system, the system that calms us down and shuts off our anxiety. Activating that nerve, activating that system shifts us into a state of rest and recovery rather than alertness. This one 2018 Japanese paper also found that just hearing laughter can improve stress, anxiety, cortisol levels, literally watching a comedy show, watching your favorite sitcom. I'm currently re-watching girls, which is like, I find that so funny.
笑声有帮助的方式是，它实际上激活了副交感神经系统。就像我说的，焦虑的对立面不是平静，而是笑声。因为当我们笑的时候，它会刺激，笑声确实会刺激迷走神经。这是我们副交感神经系统的主要组成部分，这个系统能让我们平静下来并关闭我们的焦虑。激活那条神经，激活那个系统，会将我们从警觉状态转变为休息和恢复状态。这篇2018年的日本论文还发现，仅仅听到笑声就能改善压力、焦虑和皮质醇水平，看喜剧节目、看你最喜欢的电视情景喜剧确实有效。我目前正在重看《都市女孩》，我觉得那太搞笑了。
Watching, I don't know, funniest home videos, is that still a thing? Like, no. But anything like that will, like, neurologically calm you down. If you can laugh, that is a mental and emotional circuit breaker. It is a way for your parasympathetic nervous system to say, why would I be laughing if I wasn't safe? Like this is again you playing psychological warfare like back at your anxiety. Like your anxiety wants to throw all these delusional, ridiculous situations at it. Take the ridiculousness of it and laugh at it. Laughter as a circuit breaker works because it is something that yes, triggers our parasympathetic nervous system.
看，我不知道，最搞笑家庭录像，那还是个东西吗？不。但任何类似的东西都会在神经学上让你平静下来。如果你能笑，那就是一个心理和情绪上的断路器。这是你的副交感神经系统说“如果我不安全，我为什么要笑？”的一种方式。这又是你在对你的焦虑进行心理战。你的焦虑想向你抛出所有这些妄想的、荒谬的情况。利用它的荒谬性并嘲笑它。笑声作为断路器之所以有效，是因为它确实触发了我们的副交感神经系统。
It also triggers gabber. it triggers oxytocin. Basically, imagine anxiety is like this toy train on like a circular track. It's going round and round and round. It's getting faster and faster and faster. We all know the feeling. The circuit breaker, the laughter, whatever your circuit breaker is, is like a kid, disconnecting a piece of the track, flooding the system with oxytocin, flooding the system with gabber,
它还会触发GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）。它会触发催产素。基本上，想象焦虑就像轨道上的玩具火车。它在圆形的轨道上转啊转。它越来越快。我们都知道那种感觉。断路器，笑声，无论你的断路器是什么，就像一个孩子，断开了一段轨道，用催产素淹没系统，用GABA淹没系统，
like turning it all down, switching off the batteries. I read this fantastic article from the psychologist called Dr. Lucas, who wrote about the three neurological circuit breakers that are best for anxiety. These are A, stimulating gabber and oxytocin by forcing ourselves to slow down, forcing ourselves to walk slower, eat slower, sleep more, therefore resetting ourselves. That's the first great circuit breaker. B is a parasympathetic circuit breaker, so like laughter, but also like relaxing your tongue and your jaw. I don't know if you've heard about this, but letting your mouth and jaw go slack is like a biological cheat code for relaxation. Like one of the first nodes or points of your vagus
就像把一切都调低，关掉电池。我读过心理学家卢卡斯博士写的一篇精彩文章，他写了三种最适合焦虑的神经学断路器。它们是：A，通过强迫自己慢下来、强迫自己走得更慢、吃得更慢、多睡觉来刺激GABA和催产素，从而重置自己。这是第一个伟大的断路器。B是副交感神经断路器，比如笑声，还有放松你的舌头和下巴。我不知道你是否听说过这个，让你的嘴和下巴松弛是放松的生物学作弊码。就像你的迷走神经的第一个节点或点之一
nerve is like right below your ear towards your jaw. All signals go past this point. Like all activating signals have to flow through this point to like tell your body to speed up and get stressed and get anxious. So if you reduce tension around that origin point of your vagus nerve, it is like the equivalent of holding down like the on and off button on your phone or your computer for like five seconds. Like it is a literal like you have a circuit breaker. You have an off switch like in your body that you can activate. And the final circuit breaker that Dr. Lucas talks about is ones that activate your anterior singular cortex, basically the part of of your brain that communicates between the conscious and the unconscious, instinct and executive
就在你耳朵下方靠近下巴的地方。所有信号都经过这一点。所有的激活信号都必须流经这一点，才能告诉你的身体加速、变得紧张和焦虑。所以，如果你减少迷走神经起源点周围的张力，这就相当于按住手机或电脑上的开关按钮五秒钟。这就像一个字面意义上的断路器。你的身体里有一个你可以激活的关闭开关。卢卡斯博士谈到的最后一个断路器是那些激活你的前扣带皮层的东西，基本上是你大脑中在意识和潜意识、本能和执行
functioning. We can power on that part of the brain that lets us interrupt unconscious and nonsensical thoughts by simple mindfulness exercises, by doing grounding exercises, by refocusing our attention and asking our attention to focus only on the present. So watching rain drops down a window, slowly eating and savoring a meal, doing a body scan, the 5,4, 3, 2,1 sensory technique, basically refocusing your attention outwards, only focusing on what's going around you and really syncing into that stops you from getting pulled inwards. Those are your circuit breakers, circuit breakers that work through your vagus nerve, circuit breakers that work through neurotransmitter release, circuit breakers that work through, turning on the parts of you
功能之间进行交流的部分。我们可以通过简单的正念练习、接地练习、重新聚焦我们的注意力并要求我们的注意力只关注当下，来启动大脑中让我们中断潜意识和无意义想法的部分。所以，看着雨滴顺着窗户滑落，慢慢地吃东西并品味一顿饭，做身体扫描，5-4-3-2-1感官技术，基本上是将你的注意力向外重新聚焦，只关注你周围发生的事情，并真正沉浸其中，这会阻止你被向内拉扯。这些就是你的断路器，通过迷走神经工作的断路器，通过神经递质释放工作的断路器，通过开启你那些
that can downregulate. You have the desire to help to make a real difference? The college, LaCity, you offer the program Dependence and Scenta Mental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the safety mental and of dependence. Construise a career enrichinger to service of the community francophone of all the Don't know the health in French, it's possible with the city. Visite Collage, LaCitee point CA,
能够下调的部分工作的断路器。你有帮助并做出真正改变的愿望吗？LaCité学院，你们提供依赖与心理健康项目。获得陪伴和支持面对心理健康和依赖问题的人们所需的必要能力。建立一个丰富的职业生涯，服务于法语社区。在法语中获得健康，在LaCité是可能的。访问CollageLaCitee.ca，
right now. An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Santee, Sautenue by Sante Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
现在。这是国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。在那一刻，感觉好像持续了永远。我不认为我能活下来。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, yeah. Fear to say this was the biggest case. case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder a child is as bad as it gets. I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder
这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，是的。害怕说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，先生。强奸和谋杀一个孩子是最糟糕的事情。我想也是。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个看到谋杀发生的人
take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. and to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts.
由Crevent和DePippo所为。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把它带进坟墓。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。
Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby
嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。“我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。”收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier Tchirito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、关系、情绪共存。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza?
我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消文化？克里斯蒂亚诺还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
From everyday and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait, me.
从日常平凡到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈。脆弱的一面展现出来。阴谋论被摆上桌面，目标和教训被分享。这一切在生命中都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等，我。
I'm going to be pressurably, but me going to be able to be. We are here to connect The Chicharito. And Javierito Hernandez and together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary,
我将能够，但我将能够。我们在这里连接。小豌豆。和哈维尔·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得
extraordinary. Stay close. It's a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human or IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast.
非凡。保持关注。这是一个卡拉克。哇。收听《学习做人》，在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of The Un-Housed, stories that shame and blame and paint the Un-Housed as a monolith. We The Un-House
主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的残酷描述，这些故事羞辱、指责并将无家可归者描绘成一个单一的群体。《我们，无家可归者》
is the podcast that's changing. that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator, and host. And for years, I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. We'd be in Houses a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Wichler,
是一个正在改变这一点的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，创作者和主持人。多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者可以讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQTIA+社区以及制定影响无家可归者生存法律的决策者。《我们，无家可归者》是一个两度获得Webby奖和Signal奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周请收听我对吉尔·威奇勒医生的采访，
a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weythianhous on the iHeard Radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Finally, if you really want to trick the neurological mechanisms of your anxiety to switch off for a few minutes,
一位转行做网红的街头医生，她在无家可归者社区的工作在网上和她的社区产生了巨大的影响。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们，无家可归者》。最后，如果你真的想欺骗你焦虑的神经机制，让它关闭几分钟，
it's going to sound cliche, but any kind of specifically forward movement will literally trick your brain into calming down. Now, this idea is kind of borrowed from principles of eye movement desensitization and reprocessing therapy, EMDR. It's everywhere at the moment. It's highly effective. This is most effective for people who are experiencing PTSD. However, the mechanism behind it is really interesting and can also be applied at a more basic general level. At a basic level, EMDR, or this eye movement therapy, involves something as simple as walking forward, and it uses what we call bilateral stimulation. So essentially, when you walk forward, when you do some kind of forward movement,
这听起来可能很陈词滥调，但任何形式的特定向前运动都会字面意义上欺骗你的大脑平静下来。现在，这个想法借鉴了眼动脱敏再加工疗法（EMDR）的原则。它现在无处不在。它非常有效。这对经历创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人最有效。然而，其背后的机制非常有趣，也可以应用于更基础的层面。在基础层面上，EMDR或这种眼动疗法涉及像向前行走这样简单的事情，它使用了我们所说的双侧刺激。所以本质上，当你向前走时，当你进行某种向前运动时，
the rhythmic way that your brain tracks movement from side to side, and the optic flow that it experiences from stuff moving past you, going past you. going past you, gives you the psychological sense that you are overcoming something. So essentially, if your anxiety is all in your mind, like actually let me explain this differently, when your anxiety is actually fear-based, so something is actually going wrong, when you're experiencing fear, your brain wants you to run away, wants you to fight, wants you to pursue some kind of forward movement away over or through the problem. So what it will want you do is to run away. It will want you to fight. Maybe it will want you to hide. But mainly it wants you to pursue some kind of like,
你的大脑跟踪左右运动的节奏方式，以及它从经过你的物体中体验到的光流，给你一种你正在克服某事的心理感觉。所以本质上，如果你的焦虑都在你的脑海里，实际上让我换个方式解释，当你的焦虑实际上是基于恐惧时，也就是说确实有什么事情出了问题，当你经历恐惧时，你的大脑希望你逃跑，希望你战斗，希望你追求某种远离、越过或穿过问题的向前运动。所以它会想要你做的是逃跑。它会想要你战斗。也许它会想要你躲藏。但主要是它想要你追求某种，
I am leaving the situation kind of movement. When it knows that you were experiencing that, when your brain feels that you are running away, feels that you were escaping, it will slowly turn off some of your anxiety because the anxiety or the fear is no longer needed because it's already prompted you to do what you do or to do something that is going to help you in that situation. That is like the mechanism behind fear and when there is an actual threat. When we're experiencing anxiety and the threat isn't real, we can still activate that same natural biological psychological way of activating calm by again going outside and walking, riding our bike, going to a boxing class, stimulating that same optic flow, that same bilateral
“我正在离开这种情况”的运动。当它知道你正在经历那个时，当你的大脑感觉到你正在逃跑，感觉到你正在逃脱时，它会慢慢关闭你的一些焦虑，因为焦虑或恐惧不再需要了，因为它已经促使你做你所做的事情，或者做一些在那种情况下对你有帮助的事情。这就是恐惧背后的机制，当有实际威胁时。当我们经历焦虑而威胁并不真实时，我们仍然可以通过再次走到外面去散步、骑自行车、去参加拳击课，刺激同样的光流、同样的双侧
stimulation that would ordinarily tell our brain that we are doing something about a fear stimulus, but is now telling our brain that we are doing something about this anxiety or this thing that is triggering our anxiety. Literally, walking is like the most simplest way to do this. And I know it sounds silly to be like, you're feeling anxious, go on a walk, but like motion, direction, moment. Stops you from just like stewing in the fear, neurologically, psychologically, and physically. If you are finding yourself stuck in an anxious spiral, one of the most underrated things you can do is to simply get up and walk, not on a treadmill, outside. Get up and walk around your house. Get up and do some kind of physical movement.
刺激来激活同样的自然的生物学心理方式来激活平静，这通常会告诉我们的大脑我们正在对恐惧刺激做些什么，但现在正在告诉我们的大脑我们正在对这种焦虑或触发我们焦虑的事情做些什么。字面意义上，走路是做到这一点最简单的方法。我知道说“你感到焦虑，去散步吧”听起来很傻，但运动、方向、时刻。在神经学、心理学和生理学上阻止你仅仅沉浸在恐惧中。如果你发现自己陷入了焦虑的漩涡，你能做的最被低估的事情之一就是简单地站起来走动，不是在跑步机上，而是在外面。站起来在你的房子周围走动。站起来做某种身体运动。
Same way that like doing jumping jacks, doing mountain climbers, any kind of things. physical movement calms down the body when we are in a kind of like anxious spiral because it's just saying like I'm doing something about it like it's okay you can calm down like you can we can turn that off now because I'm listening it's basically like I've listened to the siren turn off the siren we are doing our escape protocol so these are just some of the ways that we can take what we know about the neuroscientific principles and origins of anxiety and kind of twist them in our favor? I think anxiety makes it feel like our brain is not our friend and not our own. And knowing these strategies or having these strategies teaches us how to play the same game that our anxiety is
就像做开合跳、登山者式，任何种类的东西。当我们处于某种焦虑漩涡时，身体运动会使身体平静下来，因为它只是在说“我正在对此做些什么，没关系，你可以平静下来，我们可以关掉它了，因为我在听”。这基本上就像我已经听到了警报，关掉警报，我们正在执行我们的逃生协议。所以这些只是我们可以利用我们所知道的关于焦虑的神经科学原理和起源，并以某种方式将它们转化为对我们有利的方法。我认为焦虑让人觉得我们的大脑不是我们的朋友，也不是我们自己的。了解这些策略或拥有这些策略教会我们如何玩我们的焦虑正在玩的同一个游戏，
playing back at our anxiety. Or it's teaching us how to learn the quirks and patterns and kind of idiosyncrasies of our anxiety and to emulate them ourselves and kind of play them back. Like, it's definitely like a bit of a sci-op. Obviously, there are so many things that we didn't mention here. And there are so many ways, oh, there's so many factors contributing to our anxiety that have nothing to do with neuroscience and that have no neuroscientific basis at all. But I think if your main focus right now is gaining more of a scientific explanation and understanding of your anxiety, this is a really great place to start. Understanding the neurotransmitters, understanding your brain's attentional regulation systems, understanding the different parts of your
反过来对付我们的焦虑。或者它教会我们如何学习我们焦虑的怪癖、模式和特质，并亲自模仿它们，反过来对付它们。这绝对有点像心理战。显然，这里有很多我们没有提到的事情。有很多因素导致我们的焦虑，这些因素与神经科学无关，也没有任何神经科学基础。但我认为，如果你现在的主要重点是获得对你焦虑的更多科学解释和理解，这是一个很好的起点。理解神经递质，理解你大脑的注意力调节系统，理解你大脑中参与
brain that are involved in basically creating anxiety creates distance. I know some people will be like, well, that's just over intellectualizing. I know that some people will think that this is an excuse for not feeling your feelings. I still think that it's good to feel anxious. And like I said, it's a dangerous game to suppress or avoid your anxiety. but I still think it's very, very valuable. But at the end of the day, being able to say, like, this feeling is not one that I have complete ownership over, being able to reapply logic to our anxiety when anxiety likes
基本上产生焦虑的不同部分，会创造距离。我知道有些人会说，这只是过度理智化。我知道有些人会认为这是不感受你情绪的借口。我仍然认为感到焦虑是好的。就像我说的，压抑或回避你的焦虑是一场危险的游戏。但我仍然认为它非常有价值。但归根结底，能够说“这种感觉不是我完全拥有的”，能够在焦虑喜欢
to remove all logic is so, so helpful. And I think it's why, yeah, I don't know, I just think that teaching the neuroscience of anxiety is something that we should be doing more, rather than just obsessing and only focusing on the emotional side of it, only focusing on the physical side of it, only focusing on the social side of it. Like, you cannot understand why you behave the way you do in certain social situations, why you behave the way you do in work situations or any number of situations if you don't understand, like the framework and the pillars and the systems along which your anxiety is kind of running and influencing your behavior. So I hope that you enjoyed this episode. I know it was
消除所有逻辑时将逻辑重新应用于我们的焦虑，是非常非常有帮助的。我认为这就是为什么，是的，我不知道，我只是认为教授焦虑的神经科学是我们应该做更多的事情，而不是仅仅沉迷于并只关注它的情感方面，只关注它的生理方面，只关注它的社会方面。如果你不理解你的焦虑所运行并影响你行为的框架、支柱和系统，你就无法理解为什么你在某些社交场合表现得那样，为什么你在工作场合表现得那样，或者在任何数量的情况下表现得那样。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。我知道它
a little bit ranty at times. It kind of all over the place. But when I get into the science, I get so into it. But again, I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope that you learned something from it and that, you know, it just helped you understand you and your brain a little bit better as you go through an anxious moment or kind of a more anxious period of life. So with that being said, I think we're done for the day. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
有时有点唠叨。它有点到处都是。但当我进入科学领域时，我太投入了。但再次强调，我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你从中有所收获，并且，你知道，它只是帮助你更好地了解你自己和你的大脑，当你经历焦虑时刻或某种更焦虑的生活时期时。所以话虽如此，我想我们今天就到这里。注意安全，保持友善，对自己温柔一点。很快就会再谈。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevec and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry.
这把我吓坏了。人们醒醒。我是那个看到谋杀发生的人，由Crevec和DePippo所为。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把它带进坟墓。收听《魔鬼的采石场》。
Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
《Bone Valley》在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，无论你在哪里获取播客。快乐是必不可少的，它也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程，迈向更快乐的存在，《Joy 101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心和感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe is presented by CBS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast.
《Joy 101》现在收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe》由CBS呈现。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、关系、情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or Word. whenever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life?
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托尔南德斯，收听《学习做人》，在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时，会发生什么？
That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things.
那不是一个无辜者的样子。每个人都在对我撒谎，关于他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事情。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Deep Cover: The Family Man》。这里有一些事情不应该像现在这样复杂，移除种族主义雕像。这里有一些事情应该比现在容易得多，在它的位置上放一个新的。我是阿凯拉·休斯，《Rebel Spirit》第二季就是关于这两件事的。
As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，其中对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役的人的致敬更多，这意味着什么。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。这是一个iHeart播客，保证人类。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。